this was a pumpkin but I did realize
that it's also the same size - hey I'm
iffy I'm jasmine
hey i'm kenneth AKA he flawless and i'm
kelly kelly sweet and we are here today
to try some pumpkin spice food it's just
like different cuz you know it's a light
move my grandma made it one time where
are you from again I'm so San Diego that
explains why you but explains like you
get a trap pumpkin but I don't know what
pumpkin is classic is this with 2%
it's my like eggnog I don't like eggnog
you don't know you not gonna like do the
same thing you know what it was supposed
to be food period I worked at Starbucks
for four years oh wow it's not my go-to
I also don't drink coffee so what was
that like did you not like coffee before
working in no that's my life that's all
that's all you say yeah no I'm loving it
enjoy have a little yeah no I love the
pumpkin spice latte I actually think I
like more coffee flavors ah ah I like
the way the pumpkin kind of balances
with that kind of bitterness of coffee
yes yes yeah yeah so this is perfect for
yeah perfect I just think my this is
popular for sure for sure why wait for
this year-round very Caucasian
[Music]
this is serious is it
I don't dry cereal yeah they could keep
this baby naked they could keep this one
they could keep that I don't want that
No Oh more you can taste yeah yeah I
think it's like the dispersion of the
flavor yeah what it tastes like I don't
like this this is a really light pumpkin
flavor I would prefer a little bit more
flavor but for breakfast
mm-hmm good that's like great value
Applejack yes I do that's not like oh is
it like Bailey's yeah really good oh
yeah known as my alcohol like a pumpkin
spice how long because this might be my
speed you know I don't like drinking
even stuff I don't know uh what is that
ah I'm not gonna pump confirm this yeah
no because we're getting that Bailey's
coming through
yeah do you think if somebody brought
you this on ice with some whipped cream
on it you would taste it and say this is
pumpkin I took another sip you're right
I like that was thick that coated my
mouth weird that's it you see my face
when I drink it cuz you could taste
I didn't like it alone but you're
supposed to mix it with coffee so I
would drink it with my coffee I see why
I think it should be popular I mean we
drink the whole thing we talk to miss
but we drink this because we want to
feel something though it's for the
career I love this because you know the
Japanese Kit Kats have all tons of dope
dope flavors you know you have like
green tea coffee rose and we never get
that out here now this we can do this I
can do I can do this this I can do
look pumpkin pie KitKat oh wow
smell it it smells like a candle oh yeah
they they didn't company they didn't
come to play alright now we about the
you want pumpkin spice you're about to
get it I've got it I got it like it
tastes like pumpkin pie congratulations
but I don't think we needed to make that
boom yes okay because even the cookie on
the inside yeah it seems like the
pumpkin is the chocolate exterior and
then the nutmeg and cinnamon are the
wafer inside so you bite into it it's
like a reverse pumpkin pie so far I'm
disappointing because um you know I
spiced it up in the beginning I'm like
you know i spiced it up in the beginning
I'm like you know try it out and I'm on
your team this is the no pumpkin
honestly a pumpkin flavored pop-tart
makes a lot of sense to me when I think
of pop-tarts I think of like either
breakfast or like a desert type snack ya
know there's gonna be good watch cities
I could smell it I'm into it eat this
cinnamon and sugar pop-tart
you wouldn't blink twice yeah that's
true the cinnamon is coming harder yummy
pumpkin yeah but I also kind of wonder
if it's like a heating you know
sometimes pop-tart really comes into
their own I know these don't sell I know
they don't sell the kick hats they
sail'd eggnog
this is baby food pumpkin is a popular
obviously a popular flavor during a
certain time of the year it was good I
think it was all at like average level
of good nothing really like whoa Oh
actually no really God dad knows
everything was good I'd purchased all of
those things like I said I like
everything but I think you're right
they're the Kit Kat was the only stand
out of life Oh is she okay so have you
got to choose out of everything we tried
which one would you like
and we had to walk out with it what
movie to choose the Bailey oh yeah well
black person when you eat pump is
lighting my feet answers tell me that
you know I need to know everybody in the
comments below you are gonna have
good success give me the tea which I'll
think about pumping
I don't like me that's that tie me off
I'm good my stomach's upset we could
leave the pumpkins the car but we can
leave it to the Caucasian
[Music]
you